au beau milieu de ce laboratoire
hydraulique un groupe de lycéen écouteur
sur les oreilles elles suivent
attentivement le guide un salarié de DF
qui leur dit tout sur son métier cette
visite un peu particulière s'est
déroulée ce mercredi au campusedf de
Chatou une initiative de l'association
elle bouge pour promouvoir les métiers
de l'industrie auprès des filles en plus
c'est pas forcément ce qu'on voulait
faire à la base et donc du coup ça nous
a ouvert l'esprit sur le
métier découvrir les mais aussi prendre
goût pour cela des techniciennes et
ingénieurs de l'industrie étaient
présentes et les ont accompagné tout au
long de la journée et a priori le
message est plutôt bien passé les mares
nous ont dit faut être fort faut
s'imposer donc on va essayer de de faire
au mieux changement de décor la visite
se poursuit au poste de supervision
radio protection Florence une des marine
accompagne ce groupe elle déplore de ne
faire partie que des 10% en mécanique
dans sa
côté Renault par exemple on a du mal à
recruter des femmes dans les métiers
techniques donc on se dit on va aller à
la source on on va pere dire aux femmes
mais dirigez-vous aussi sur les métiers
techniques il y a rien de tabou enfin un
peu cassé des des stéréotypes des
stéréotypes qu'ell bougent cherchent à
dépasser car actuellement les femmes
sont encore sous représentées dans ce
secteur les femmes sont environ 27 %
dans les effectifs des écoles
d'ingénieurs et elle représente 17 %
dans dans l'industrie ça veut dire qu'il
y a une perte en ligne sérieuse et c'est
bien dommage car ce sont des secteurs
qui emploient un secteur qui emploie
principalement des ingénieurs dans les
ivelines l'industrie représente 19 % de
l'activité